une salve de missile russe dans le ciel
de Kiev et neutralisée par la défense
aérienne ukrainienne
vers 2h30 les envahisseurs russes sont
attaqués l'Ukraine avec leur aviation
qui a tiré 18 missiles de croisière
également ciblée les régions de Helson
au sud et celle de dieppewsk à l'est ou
plusieurs établissements scolaires
commerce et habitations ont été
endommagés à pavload ville de 100000
habitants avant l'offensive de février
2023 plusieurs cratères témoignent de la
violence des frappes
cet habitant a été surpris chez lui en
pleine nuit
quand j'ai entendu la première explosion
j'écris à ma femme
habille-toi rapidement et sort
j'ai à peine eu le temps d'enfiler ça
à peine avant nous eu le temps d'arriver
dans le couloir qu'il y a eu une autre
explosion
si forte que j'ai été renversé
un immeuble qui a été frappé comme 18
autres dans la ville
une explosion à enfoncer la porte de
cette chambre c'était difficile d'entrer
nous n'avons pas dormi de la nuit
mon enfant aura besoin de soutien
psychologique c'était horrible
cette salle de missile russe survient
alors qu'une attaque au drone attribuait
à l'Ukraine a touché samedi un dépôt de
pétrole à Sébastopol en Crimée un excès
et qu'un engin explosif a provoqué lundi
le déraillement d'un train de
marchandises dans une région russe
frontalière